I deal with
in my day-to-day life,
the sound of the highway
that I literally
live right next to.
( in Spanish )
It's all the time.
I noticed most early
in the morning
when the planes
that fly overnight
would wake me up.
I have a 13-year-old
and sometimes he gets up
in the middle
of the night and says,
"Mom, I can't sleep because
of the airplane noise."
( in Spanish )
Yes, I think it's not just me,
but all of the residents
of Chelsea have noticed.
I think you feel it,
because all day
you hear noise.
For example,
I work in a restaurant.
You hear noise from
the smoke fans in the kitchen,
you hear the noise
of the plates.
And you get to your house,
sit down,
and you want to relax a bit
and you're hearing the noise
from the planes passing
constantly.
( in Spanish )
We're an undocumented
community.
We're a community
of immigrants.
We come from our countries
resigned to the fact
that they won't listen to us,
and so sometimes we're afraid
to raise our voices.
I don't know if we could
have a schedule
for stopping
the flights at night.
What we have to do
is organize the people
so that our complaints
are heard.
( in Spanish )
It effects me emotionally.
When we don't rest well,
your nerves
are a bit altered.
¡Pásale, pásale,
pásale, pásale!
Yeah, to me that is
the sound of Mexico City.